[Music]
let me tell you a little secret our
master of microscopes james will
occasionally just email us pictures that
he has taken of the micro cosmos that
are just stunning we will get them and
then we'll all fawn over them for a
little bit and we'll all feel very
special that we got to see something so
amazing that brightened up our work day
a little bit
because as we hope you have discovered
from watching this channel there is
beauty in the invisible and there is joy
in letting yourself just
fall into it for a while
and so
we've decided that we want to invite you
into that as well we've put together 13
of james's stunning images in the 2023
journey to the micro cosmos calendar
each image is accompanied by a little
blurb explaining what you're looking at
and each photo showcases both james's
work as an artist and of course the
beauty of the micro cosmos
plus you're probably going to get a 20
23 wall calendar so why not support your
favorite microscopic youtube channel at
the same time
you can find it at
complexlycalendars.com where some of the
other shows from complexly the company
that produces this show also have
calendars available there's scishow and
scishow space bizarre beasts and eons or
if you don't want to type all that stuff
out you can just click on the link in
the description or in the pinned comment
or
anywhere else we could find to put it
we're really excited to share the micro
cosmos with you in all of the ways that
we do but we only made a pretty limited
number of these so we think they might
sell out pretty fast to get yours you
can go to
complexlycalendars.com and again the
link
is somewhere nearby
[Music]